la llamada pausa estratégica de las
fuerzas rusas en esta lucha por la
región del donbass tiene una doble
faceta si bien las tropas no avanzan con
la intensidad y no atacan con artillería
de la manera tan intensa como lo
hicieron semanas atrás cuando trataban
de tomar el control de severodonezk
ilicic ags en la provincia de luján que
hoy en control de las fuerzas rusas si
siguen atacando las principales ciudades
de esta provincia de don es que estamos
en la ciudad de grama tos que fue
atacada en el día de hoy en la noche por
un misil que cayó en la plaza central
afortunadamente no hubo víctimas humanas
pero sí hubo ataques en otros sectores
de la ciudad y otras ciudades también de
la provincia pero sin embargo la gran
noticia o en la gran preocupación en el
día de hoy viene de esa central nuclear
la más grande de europa en la ciudad de
savory allá en el centro del país que
está en control de las fuerzas rusas y
hoy una autoridad desde kiev de la
energía atómica ucraniana decía que
éstas 500 efectivos que estaban allí
estarían desplazando grandes armamento
dentro de esta planta nuclear donde
podrían atacar otras regiones de ucrania
especialmente esas grandes ciudades al
otro lado del río ni pro recordemos que
anoche fue atacada la ciudad de denny
pro con 6 misiles que fueron lanzados
cuatro de ellos interceptados dos de
ellos cayeron en lugares centrales de la
ciudad dejando tres personas muertas y
15 heridos